ever wanted to customize your own unique
oneon-one merch with the power of AI you
can these tote bags featuring our
favorite Beholder look really cool what
do you guys think here's how we put it
together first we make the image with
Bing image Creator K in a few Proms and
there we have it the system takes a few
moments to put it all together each prom
gives you four options to pick from and
if you're not sure if other designs are
better it's it's all saved on the back
end as well we like this design quite a
bit but what happens if we change up and
give it more pixel treatment we use the
same prompt and added pixel style at the
end this is how it looks like the more
specific you are the better the outcomes
the image generator can put together
time to send it out for layout and print
I think all of this is really cool and
the best part of it all the big image
Creator is free and you should go check
it out thanks Microsoft